[Musique]
pas de confinement france mais la
décision pourrait être prise à tout
comme le délicat jeu d'équilibriste du
gouvernement qui à la surprise générale
a finalement décidé de maintenir le
couvre-feu avec de nouvelles
restrictions
bien qu'une nouvelle vague de kobe 19,3
à craindre en raison des variantes du
gorna virus le ministre de la santé dit
aujourd'hui espérer pouvoir l'éviter les
heures que nous vivons sont cruciales
azul a twitté hier emmanuel bach
l algérie a démarré sa campagne de
vaccination restent avec leurs maigres
ressources publiques mais que le pays
vaccine sa population les premières
doses sont arrivés vendredi par vol
militaire priorité donnée au corps
médical aux seniors et aux personnes
souffrant de maladies chroniques
objectif vacciner 80 % des jeunes
nouvelle journée de mobilisation en
russie on soutient alexeï navalni
l'opposante incarcérée pour ne pas avoir
respecté les conditions de sa peine de
prison avec sursis
ses partisans demandent sa libération et
des rassemblements non autorisés pour le
deuxième week-end consécutif selon les
ong ou vd info plusieurs centaines de
personnes ont été quand à recoller
[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue séoul gagné sur rt
france on s'attendait à ce que manuel
macro prennent la parole ces jours ci
c'est finalement le premier ministre qui
a tenu un point presse vendredi à
l'issue d'un conseil de défense
à la surprise générale pas de
confinement annoncé mais de nouvelles
mesures le chef de l'état s'est lui
finalement exprimée par tweet hier
faisant le pari de la confiance emmanuel
macron a déclaré que les heures que nous
vivons sont cruciales avant d'appeler à
la responsabilité
l'exécutif marche sur des oeufs la
pression épidémique est forte
une nouvelle vague est à redouter en
raison des effets des variants du cornât
virus mais la ministre de la santé
espèrent pouvoir l'éviter
tout laisse à penser qu'une nouvelle
vague pourrait se profiler à cause du
variant mais peut-être pourra-t-on
l'éviter grâce aux mesures que nous
avons décidé tous et que les français
respectent
l'idée c'est de gagner du temps de
limiter la casse si l'incidence
repartait à la hausse
nous n'hésiterions pas nous n'avons
jamais dit que nous ne leur confie ne
rions pas dans les quinze jours à venir
si c'était nécessaire frontières
désormais bouclée sur pays extérieurs à
l'union européenne fermeture des
surfaces commerciales de plus de 20
mille mètres carrés c'est donc le choix
pour l'heure de l'exécutif de nouvelles
mesures entrées en vigueur ce dimanche
les détails c'est avec ne me verra
période de sursis pour les français
alors qu'un troisième confinement
semblait imminent jean castex a écarté
cette piste pour le moment la question
d'un confinement se pose légitimement
compte tenu de ces données
mais nous en connaissons l'impact très
lourd pour les français sur tous les
plans
ce soir nous considérons au regard des
chiffres des derniers jours que nous
pouvons encore nous donner une chance de
l'éviter mais les français ne sont pas à
l'abri d'une nouvelle mise sous cloche
le premier ministre concède que les
prochains jours seront déterminants
en cas de confinement celui ci serait
envisagée sous une forme dite hybride
rallongement des vacances de février
pour les élèves prise de rendez-vous
dans les commerces maintien d'un jour en
présentiel pour les étudiants le
gouvernement temporise en instaurant des
mesures
or alternatives afin de lutter contre la
nette augmentation de cas de kovy 19
mais surtout de ces variants nous avons
décidé de prendre sans délai les mesures
complémentaires suivantes toutes entrées
en france et toute sortie de notre
territoire à destination ou en
provenance d'un pays extérieurs à
l'union européenne sera interdite sauf
motif impérieux d mesure entrée en
vigueur dès ce dimanche minuit les
contrôles du couvre-feu de 18h seront
également renforcés autre mesure
annoncée le renforcement du recours au
télétravail par les entreprises et les
salariés lundi une concertation est
prévue à ce sujet avec les partenaires
sociaux et commerces non essentiels
pourront rester ouverts à l'exception
des très grandes surfaces les centres
commerciaux non alimentaire d'une
surface supérieure à vingt mille mètres
carrés c'est à dire ceux qui favorisent
le plus de brassage des populations
seront fermés le quoi qu'il en coûte
prêts garantis par l'état fonds de
solidarité chômage partiel s'appliquera
bien sûr pour tous des salariés et des
entreprises concernées
ces annonces jugées pas assez strictes
ont déçu une partie des médecins pour
eux le choix de ne pas re confiné d'un
parent et sanitaires risqué en france la
pression épidémique reste forte plus de
24000 nouvelles contaminations ont été
rapportés ces dernières 24 heures et en
plus des conséquences économiques d'un
troisième confinement se pose la
question de l'adhésion de la population
une telle mesure
ces derniers jours quelques mouvements
de désobéissance civile ont en effet été
observés des restaurateurs qui appelle à
rouvrir les établissements hier ce sont
les théâtres et lieux culturels qui ont
répondu à l'appel national lancé par
laurent rochus ce directeur de théâtre à
avignon avait demandé aux acteurs de la
culture d'ouvrir leur établissement
pendant une heure pour des
on sait leur fermeture imposée autre
exemple à marseille avec isabelle carré
sco c'est isabelle terrières au coeur de
marseille
ce théâtre à braver l'interdît hier en
ouvrant ses portes pour un moment des
changes avec l'une de ses comédiennes et
auteur de one woman show audrey vernon
le théâtre l'art ainsi fait écho à un
cri de colère celui du directeur de
l'ens factory avignon qui a appelé à
ouvrir pendant une heure tous les
théâtres et lieux de culture ce samedi
une quarantaine de théâtre en france ont
répondu présent l'idée de participer
donc pour ma part c'est pas forcément
dans un esprit rebelle c'est juste pas
déjà pour ouvrir nos portes pour le
moral ça fait du bien premièrement la le
l'occasion était trop belle donc pour
dire à tout l'état de france avec nous
dira en signe de protestation deux pour
montrer un petit peu l'absurdité de la
situation actuelle on veut vraiment
rappeler qu'il n'ya pas deux il ya
jamais eu aucun cluster dans aucun
théâtre de france jusqu'à présent tout
ce journal
la conférence comme les boissons pour
les organisateurs il s'agit avant tout
de partager de retrouver le public les
lieux de culture et d'intelligence soit
fermée c'est très inquiétant est le fait
qu'il n'y ait plus que des endroits
marchand où on est le droit d'aller ça
aussi c'est très inquiétant c'est on
dirait qu'il ya plus d espace de
gratuité finalement de discussion je me
rends compte à quel point les
interactions sociales et humaines sont
importantes au niveau de la santé du
bien-être
le spectacle de rêveur non d'hillion
dollar baby était programmée au théâtre
fin 2019 mais n'a pu être joué en raison
du couvre feu puis du second confinement
en attendant de retrouver officiellement
son public
la comédienne a pu partager avec lui un
moment des changes mêlant humour et
engagement las d'être sur scène
aujourd'hui enfin c'est super g je suis
très contente
et puis surtout je suis très contente
qui est de théâtre en france qui face à
qui ouvrent leurs portes dans une
démarche totalement non marchandes ça
aussi je trouve ça important dans la
salle une vingtaine de spectateurs sont
venus pour soutenir la culture exprimé
leur besoin d'art et d'évasion mais
aussi pour manifester leur désaccord
avec la politique sanitaire
c'est un rappel pour nous de dire sans
la culture
mais effectivement il ya beaucoup de
gens qui
qu'ils commencent à se sentir un petit
peu en détresse et surtout quand ça fait
partie moi ça fait partie de mon mode de
vie de faire une à deux sorties
culturelles par semaine et là sans ça je
me retrouve à
j'en trouve de la culture mais j'suis
pas nourri de la même façon on se rend
compte que que la culture va mal et que
malgré tous les efforts des directeurs
des responsables aujourd'hui la culture
est en train de mourir à petit feu et et
voire même sacrifié tout en sachant que
c'est pas forcément les lieux où on est
allé les plus forte contamination voire
quasiment pas quoi chaque participant
risquer une amende de 135 euros
le gérant s'exposant lui à 1500 euros de
pénalités accompagné d'une fermeture
administrative de son établissement et
l'espoir de sortir de la crise réside en
partie dans la vaccination encore
faut-il que les états puissent
poursuivre leur campagne car les
laboratoires accuse du retard dans la
livraison de la romaine
le gouvernement allemand menaces
d'actions en justice s'ils ne respectent
pas leurs obligations vis-à-vis de
l'union européenne d'une lieu qui a
adopté vendredi un mécanisme pour
contrôler à l'exportation hors de ses
frontières des vaccins contre l'accord
d'un virus qui sont produits bruxelles
veut s'assurer d'empêcher la sortie de
doses destinées aux européens
de quoi provoquer la colère de londres
qui a estimé que cela ne respectait pas
vraiment le break site
emmanuel macron à l'udaf et le royaume
uni à se positionner vis-à-vis de dieu
quelle politique la grande bretagne at
elle envie de choisir elle ne peut pas
être le meilleur allié des états unis le
meilleur allié de l'union européenne et
le nouveau singapour et donc il faut
choisir un modèle
moi mon souhait c'est qu'on ait des
relations pacifiques constructive
parce que je crois très profondément
qu'on a un destin lié que nos
intellectuels sont liés qu'on pense
ensemble le monde avec nos différences
mais que nos chercheurs ont un destin
lié et que nos industriels travaillent
ensemble lé regard de frédéric viale il
est spécialiste des questions
européennes bretagne a obtenu tout ce qu
elle tout ce qu'elle souhaitait c'est
assez normal d'ailleurs parce que au
fond l'union européenne n'a pas
véritablement de projets en dehors de
l'application des règles de la
concurrence et de la libre circulation
des capitaux
la grande bretagne voulait ça aussi elle
a obtenu est donc pour reprendre la
petite citation de macron qui dit
la grande bretagne doit choisir elle ne
peut pas être en même temps le meilleur
allié des états unis le meilleur ami
l'union européenne et singapour
et bien malheureusement on aura les
trois c'est à dire que la grande
bretagne va poursuivre sa politique qui
consiste à être la tête de pont des
états unis près l'union européenne et le
paradis fiscal qu'elle n'a jamais cessé
d'être
y compris quand elle était membre
d'union européenne a les oppose entre à
l'ouverture de la pma à toutes les
femmes étaient de nouveau dans la rue ce
dimanche ils espèrent peser sur les
débats
alors que le projet de loi bioéthique
sera de retour au sénat à partir de
mardi une mobilisation nationale
notre reporter david khalifa lui suivi
le rassemblement parisien
un rassemblement qui s'est achevée à
17h15 ici devant le ministère de la
santé l'objectif de cette manifestation
contre le projet de loi bioéthique
c'était à d'interpeller le gouvernement
met en priorité
vous l'aurez compris olivier ferrand
afin à qu'il réécrive en profondeur ce
projet de loi bioéthique qui sera en
deuxième lecture à cette semaine au
sénat malgré des conditions
météorologiques difficiles la
mobilisation était au rendez vous
puisque plusieurs centaines de personnes
se sont réunies à ici la plupart à
dénonce un commerce de la vie écouter
pour lutter contre la marchandisation du
corps humain c'est un des derniers
endroits où on n'est pas dans les
intérêts financiers où on n'est pas si
parler les forces du marché
c'est un dernier espace de gratuité qui
me semble important de préserver pour
pour nous et surtout pour les
générations futures
fallait absolument être là aujourd'hui
pour réactualiser le mouvement s'il ya
bien une manifestation il ya une semaine
et il faut le réactualiser ce moment il
faut qu'il entende
il faut qu'il entende notre cri parce
que notre cri n'est pas bourdonne me dit
personnes
il est pour l'humanité c'est la nuit
dépasse complètement ce sujet
sujet qui est anthropologique et donc on
ne peut pas se taire à l'initiative de
ce rassemblement le collectif manif pour
tous sa présidente ludivine de la
recherche était un présente à des élus
politiques également venus apporter leur
soutien à cette manifestation est c'est
le cas de marc meyer maire de cette
ville je vous propose de les écouter en
très bref ce que nous demandons c'est le
retrait de ce projet de loi de
bioéthique ce n'est pas le moment
olivier verront le ministre de la santé
qui est le premier à porter ce texte
comme ministre de la santé à d'autres
urgences à traiter d'autres priorités il
est en grande difficulté
les français souffrent et nous demandons
aux sénateurs qu'ils ne soient pas comme
la feuille morte au vent qui veulent au
gré des avis et des opinions
mais qu'ils sachent tout simplement
reconnaître et prendre en compte le fait
que tous les enfants y compris les
enfants nés par pma ont besoin
évidemment et le droit dans la mesure du
possible d'avoir un père et une mère
nous nous craignons en tant que citoyen
et en tant qu'élu également que demain
on glisse vers de l'eugénisme c'est à
dire une sélection des embryons à partir
de critères que les parents décideront
entre eux mais ces critères vont nous
engager sur la voie de la sélection par
volonté propre de notre humanité
tout cela vous voyez vous nous inquiète
particulièrement
c'est pourquoi nous demandons au sénat
de réécrire en profondeur ce texte est
mieux son corps évidemment notre souhait
ce serait de suspendre le parcours
parlementaire de ce texte
l'objectif premier de ce rassemblement
c'est la réécriture en profondeur de ce
projet de loi bioéthique et notamment de
l'article 1er qui autorise la
procréation médicalement assistée
son motif médical et sans père en tout
cas à ce rassemblement un ca déroulée de
manière assez festive
plusieurs prises de parole se sont
déroulés un sur cette scène et que vous
voyez est derrière moi un important
dispositif de sécurité a été mis en
place
également afin d'éviter tout débordement
puisque plusieurs débordements ont eu
lieu hier lors des différents
rassemblements contre ce projet de loi
bioéthique la loi bioéthique
prévoit également la systématisation de
la prise en compte de la détresse
psychosocial pour les mg l'interruption
médicale de grossesse
nous en avons parlé avec nos invités
rémi tales fondateur de marianne conseil
et michael greenberg chef du service de
la reproduction et préservation de la
fertilité à l'hôpital antoine béclère de
clamart la possibilité que ce texte
introduit pour toute femme jusqu'au test
jusqu'au terme de sa grossesse de
procéder à une interruption médicale de
grossesse au simple motif d'une pratique
sociale il faut que chacun se rend bien
compte de ce que cela signifie
ça signifie qu'on va utah nasier des
enfants très concrètement 6 à 8 mois 9
mois
une femme vient il se déclare en
situation de détresse psychosociale
deuxième exemple la création d'individus
chimères c'est-à-dire de l'hybride
en fait entre l'être humain et l'animal
dont la ministre frédéric vidal était
incapable de garantir que ces individus
chimères ne seraient pas dotés d'une
conscience humaine
imaginez un petit peu le monde dans
lequel on évolue je crois que c'est
quelque chose d'effroyable après la
question de la détresse sic au social
des femmes et la possibilité d'étendre
cette interruption médicale de grossesse
dans ce contexte là aujourd'hui
bien entendu que c'est une possibilité
mais ça va être particulièrement encadré
il faut pas croire qu'on va se mettre à
faire des interruptions volontaires de
grossesse pour des femmes jusqu'à
jusqu'à neuf mois c'est pas ça la
réalité c'est pas comme ça que ça va se
passer et c'est l'interruption médicale
de grossesse pour des presses
psychosociale ce sont des drames qui se
passe pour les femmes c'est pas une
femme qui se dit c'est pas le bon moment
pour moi d'avoir une grossesse et c est
verrouillé par x commission avant de
pouvoir lactée parce que nous savons en
tant que médecin que l'être un terme à
une grossesse pour un contexte
psychosocial qui n'est pas une
problématique médicale au sens premier
du terme avec un risque pour l'enfant à
proprement parler un risque médical et
bien dans ces situations-là et liens
dans ces situations rare mais pour
lesquels elle pense qu'il va se passer
possiblement un drame pour l'enfant ou
pour la mer et lien il y à il y aura
dans des cas exceptionnels la
possibilité d'interrompre
s quelles sont les origines de la
pandémie c'est à cette question que vont
tenter de répondre les experts de
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
ils se sont rendus ce dimanche au marché
de wanna know râle là où le cor n'avait
russe est apparue fin 2019 sur place des
journalistes mais seul véhicule des
enquêteurs ont été autorisés à entrer
le marché est fermé depuis janvier 2020
c'est ici qu'ils étaient notamment vendu
des animaux sauvages vivent les experts
à où commencer leurs recherches au
vendredi après avoir passé 14 jours en
quarantaine une visite sensibles pour
pékin pointé du doigt pour avoir tardé à
réagir dès les premiers cas de
contamination
les premières doses du vaccin rue
spoutnik v sont arrivés vendredi en
algérie le pays a lancé dans la foulée
sa campagne de vaccination objectif 80%
d'algériens vacciner le coup d'envoi a
été donné à blida premier foyer de la
maladie en algérie est l'une des villes
les plus touchées
ce dimanche une autre cargaison cette
fois ci du vaccin astrazeneca est arrivé
à alger avant d'autres livraisons
attendues en provenance de chine et
d'inde notamment emilie google
première vaccination pour cette
algérienne membre du personnel médical
elle est prioritaire pour bénéficier
d'une dose de spoutnik v les membres du
personnel médical sont en première ligne
pour combattre le virus
il est donc logique qu'ils soient les
premières recevoir le vaccin
ce samedi les premières doses ont
également bénéficié aux personnes
atteintes de maladies chroniques et aux
personnes âgées
un soulagement pour cette habitante de
blida cette ville située au sud ouest de
la capitale a été le premier foyer de
kovy 19 en algérie c'est mon fils qui
m'a parlé de la vaccination et j'en ai
été très heureuse alors je suis venu
aussi vite que j'ai pu au moins ça nous
permettra d'avoir un peu de repos et
d'arrêter d'être stressé de devoir nous
montrer si prudent toute la journée
que dieu nous protège de ce fléau je
suis jeune je n'ai pas de maladies
chroniques et je suis venu pour donner
l'exemple jeunes de ma région et aux
algériens en général pour qu'il n'ait
pas peur et qu'ils puissent être
vaccinés dès ce dimanche
la campagne de vaccination s'étend au
personnel de sécurité aux agents de la
protection civile aux enseignants ou
encore aux imams à alger doit aussi
réceptionner un premier lot du vaccin
britannique d'astrazeneca et oxford pour
faire face à la pandémie
quelques 8000 centres de santé sont
mobilisés à travers le pays où près de
trente gouvernorats sont soumis à un
couvre-feu partiel selon le dernier
bilan officiel
le nombre de contaminations aux kovy 19
approche officiellement des cent sept
mille cas avec environ 2900 et c'est au
pérou fous les hôpitaux sont au bord de
la saturation frein confinement strict
cette entrée en vigueur ce dimanche des
restrictions qui passe mal auprès d'une
partie des péruviens quentin au clair
le confinement ils n'en veulent plus des
dizaines de manifestants ont défilé dans
les rues de lima ce samedi contre le
nouveau tour de vis des autorités un
confinement de deux semaines comment ce
dimanche dans la capitale péruvienne et
dans neuf autres régions du pays
les liaisons aériennes sont également
suspendus avec le brésil et l'europe
dans le but d'endiguer la propagation de
nouveaux variants ces derniers jours la
situation sanitaire s'est sérieusement
dégradé dans le pays
illustration à lima où plusieurs
dizaines de paires vient dorment dans
les rues dans l'espoir de repartir avec
une bouteille d'oxygène plein hier il ya
une longue file d'attenté hier à 5
heures du matin mais je suis arrivé bien
tard parce que je crois qu'il ya des
gens qui dorment ici depuis deux ou
trois jours
hier je suis arrivé ici à 21h et depuis
21h nous attendons que les bouteilles
d'oxygène soir nous avons besoin
d'oxygène pour que notre thème et si
nous n'avons pas d'oxygène
notre famille l'amour et le système de
santé péruviens se retrouve au bord de
l'effondrement
dans cet hôpital de la capitale l'unité
de soins intensifs est saturé et ne peut
faire face à l'afflux grandissant de
patients atteints par cette nouvelle
vague de contamination ce n'est pas
quelque chose que l'on prend à la légère
que chacun prenne conscience de ce que
nous vivons maintenant des gens sont en
train de mourir
nous n'avons pas assez de lits
disponibles ni assez de personnel pour
nous aider le personnel aussi est
fatigué épuisé et malade est la seule
façon pour les gens de nous aider et de
rester chez eux de respecter une
distance physique et de porter le masque
celui lits sont actuellement disponibles
en soin intensif dans les hôpitaux de
lima une situation critique
alors que le pérou a déjà recensé plus
de 40000 mort du co vie de 19 depuis le
début de la pandémie
un nouveau dimanche de mobilisation en
russie pour les partisans d'alexei
navalni l'opposant est incarcéré pour ne
pas avoir respecté les conditions de sa
peine de prison avec sursis
ces soutiens demande sa libération pour
le deuxième week-end consécutif ils se
sont réunis au camp de rassemblement
interdit par les autorités
selon les ong à aubes et des infos
plusieurs centaines de personnes ont été
arrêtées principalement à moscou dont
une soixantaine de journalistes selon le
chef de l'union des journalistes russes
l'union européenne déplore des
interpellations massives
le secrétaire d'état américain anthony
blinken pointe lui du doigt je cite
lusage persistant de tactiques brutales
de la russie contre des manifestants
pacifiques et des journalistes il
appelle les autorités russes à libérer
alexeï navalni et ses soutiens
réponse de moscou qui dénonce les
ingérences grossières des états unis
dans ses affaires intérieures
la correspondance à moscou d'antoine
frérot à aucun moment les organisateurs
du rassemblement n'ont réussi à faire ce
qu'ils souhaitaient à savoir réunir un
maximum de gens à un endroit donné
le plan initial était de rassembler un
maximum de personnes au niveau de la
place de la loubianka symboliquement
devant le siège du fsb mais voilà les
forces de police ont complètement bouclé
le périmètre et fait fermer les stations
de métro qui aurait permis de s'y rendre
en conséquence les organisateurs via
leur canal instagram dédiés ont proposé
ont désigné plusieurs autres endroits
afin de s'y rassembler mais à chaque
fois le même schéma les forces de police
qui boucle le périmètre et qui ferme la
station de métro la plus proche résultat
pas de grandes pas de grand
rassemblement statique comme c'était le
cas la semaine dernière mais plutôt un
cortège de sans doute plusieurs milliers
de personnes qui déambulent dans le
centre de la capitale
bien sûr cela n'a pas empêché des
arrestations d'avoir lieu encore une
fois sûrement plusieurs centaines
d'arrestations
mardi ce sera au tour d'alexis navalni
de passer devant le juge pour les
violation de sa période de probation on
saura donc mardi 6 à peine de prison
avec sursis ou tout du moins une partie
de cette peine avec sursis sera commuer
ou non en peine de prison ferme
la capitale russe qui face à la baisse
du nombre de contaminations de kobe 19 à
alléger ces restrictions sanitaires bars
restaurants et boîtes de nuit peuvent
désormais rester ouverts après 23h
reportage de faire un cauchemar
les températures - 0 la neige le verglas
ce ne sont pas des raisons pour les
moscovites de rester à la maison ce
vendredi soir surtout s'il s'agit d'un
premier vendredi
depuis deux mois de levée d'interdiction
pour les restaurants et les boîtes de
nuit de travail et après 23 heures
honnêtement nous sommes vraiment heureux
que la quarantaine était élevé parce que
les jeunes ont vraiment besoin de sortir
le fait que des établissements qui
travaillent pour nous nous accueille
avec leurs portes ouvertes est
évidemment très positif
il ne peut en être autrement qui est
habitué c'est moscou une mégapole est
ici tout doit fonctionner pour le client
nous souhaitons à tous une bonne santé
que personne ne tombe malade nous
espérons tous que la pandémie nous
quittera bientôt et que nous
n'oublierons tous comme un mauvais rêve
l'assouplissement des restrictions entre
en vigueur après une amélioration stable
de la situation épidémiologique
le nombre de nouveaux malades ne dépasse
pas 2 3 milles par jour depuis une
semaine
50 % des lits dédiés aux malades de
coronavirus sont libres pour la première
fois depuis juillet on l'attendait avec
impatience c'est une nouvelle très
importante et grandiose pour nous si on
revient disons en mars 2020 cette
période a bien sûr été très difficile
pour nous moscou est une ville nocturne
en général il est donc très difficile
d'imaginer moscou sans cette ville de
nuit moi je suis pour le retour à notre
ancienne vie avant la pandémie le
printemps et l'été arrive notre belle
véranda sera ouverte
je suis donc absolument pour le retour à
l'ancienne vie c'est avec espoir pour
ainsi dire que je regarde l'avenir
oui l e coronavirus n'est pas encore
rompu mais l'on peut déjà affrontées à
la fin de la pandémie au moins à mon cou
et c'est la fin de cette édition je vous
retrouve dans une trentaine de minutes
pour un nouveau journal à tout à l'heure
[Musique]
l'hypothèse de rendre obligatoire le
vaccin pose problème ce qui est en cause
c'est votre liberté
mais ce qui est en cause aussi c'est la
liberté des autres
et entre la liberté individuelle et la
liberté collective il faut choisir la la
la gouvernance est compliqué la pandémie
après les gilets jaunes le terrorisme
islamique ça fait quand même beaucoup
tout ça le fondement la politique c'est
la rumeur ont réagi à des rumeurs et
plus qu'à des réalités ça comme
conséquence que la politique est devenue
un métier du spectacle
la loi est un objet de communication
politique trop de lois tuent la loi d'
et les lois inutiles q les beaunois
à
[Musique]